Liz we want to talk about another big
story in the region this is North
Korea's rise in tension with the u.s. US
as you know says it that the military
fired three missiles yesterday and the
second launch in a week u.s. also
revealed that it seized a North Korean
cargo ship in violation of economic
sanctions this morning North Korea says
Kim jong-un is telling his military to
keep full combat posture their words so
what can you tell us about this well
let's start with those missile launches
yesterday - most analysts they look less
like a show of force than a grab for
attention North Korean state media
released these pictures showing a
gleeful kim jonghwan apparently watching
those missile tests yesterday it's the
second drill he's observed in the past
week North Korean state media avoided
specifying what the weapons were but the
US military says they were three
ballistic missiles
not enough said president Trump to ruin
his relationship with Kim jong-un
they were smaller missiles and
short-range missiles nobody's happy
about it but we'll take it a good look
and we'll see we'll say the relationship
continues but we'll see what happens but
these are the first missile launches
since 2017 and a sure sign that Kim
jong-un is becoming frustrated after the
last summit with President Trump
collapsed however this week's launches
are not enough of a provocation to
derail future talks says geopolitical
analyst Thomas Anderson they certainly
are not going to prevent another summit
and it's not as if it is a
intercontinental range missile and it's
not the testing of a nuclear warhead
these are the two elements that Kim
jong-un promised he would put a
moratorium on technically that
moratorium still holds but Kim has
already warned the United States to
change its position or there will be no
third summit and ratcheting up tensions
between the two countries even further
the United States announced that it had
seized a huge North Korean cargo ship
off the coast of Indonesia
now that's the first time a US has
actually detained a Korean ship it
happened last April but it shows you
that the u.s. is very serious about
choking off any and all revenue going to
North Korea that could in fact be
funneled into developing its nuclear
program Nora we will continue to watch
that very very closely Elizabeth Palmer
in Beijing thank you so much